let's check out the story real quick so
this is from buzzfeed they say
lil baby's powerful grammy performance
that referenced george floyd gave me
chills
he deserves an award just for that
performance they say my god he just
did the damn thing amazing so he's like
wearing this fake bulletproof vest
and they show this mock incident of ray
sharp brooks now for those that don't
don't remember ray shark brooks was the
guy who was driving drunk
and he was in the wendy's drive-thru
when he passed out drunk because he
wouldn't move
someone called the cops maybe in the
restaurant when the police showed up
they were like you know out of the
vehicle you've had too much to drink
when they tried to arrest him
he actually fought the cops punched one
of the cops in the face there's multiple
camera angles of the security footage
body cams
and then actually grabbed the taser and
hit one of the cops with it knock him to
the ground the cop hit his head got a
concussion
when he ran for it the cop the other cop
gave chase
rachar brooks turned and then fired the
second cartridge from the taser
and that's when the cop drew his weapon
and shot the guy twice
and it killed him we saw a lot of media
propaganda they put out this fake clip
this fake
this fake still from the incident where
they tried claiming the cop kicked the
guy when he was down kicked brooks when
he's down
it didn't happen but now what we're
seeing at the grammys of all things
is they're doing this reenactment where
in the reenactment it's like the guy
just peacefully gets in the ground and
like puts his hands up
and it is not at all what you see in the
actual body camera footage
for those that don't actually know the
story they would see this
and they would believe the activist
narrative as opposed to the actual truth
this is one of the biggest problems we
have right now i think in the country
is that a lot of people they get their
information second hand
they get it distilled by people with
political motives and agendas and that's
true of this show
and it's true of the grammys granted i
think we're a bit more discerning and a
bit
more honest on this show and there are
many other political commentators who
will be more honest but for the most
part
when it filters through people with
agendas you get lies and
misrepresentations
but the bigger thing about this was that
they brought out team tamika mallory
the reason that's interesting is because
she's been accused of pushing into
medical conspiracy theories this is by
the new york times
and it made everybody really question
the women's march of which she was one
of the principal organizers
and i think there was a big controversy
like some groups broke up some pulled
out
a bunch of actors were like we don't
want to be involved in this because
she's got
questionable uh associations in this
uh a speech or whatever she said we
don't need allies we need accomplices
and the crazy thing is when they're
doing this depiction of riots as kind of
a good thing
and they're having this activist come
out and say these things i think it's
actually
fairly worrying so i guess the bigger
question though is
the political ramifications of this and
whether or not we should actually even
care about the grammys both because
it's a trap it's trash and the writings
are trash and no one cares about the
grammys or more importantly because
should we get all hot and bothered by
offensive performances
you know because we don't like it so
raka considering
you're you you do these videos you
clearly have no issue
um what's the right word being a
troublemaker i guess i'm curious
actually what you think
about you know this kind of stuff i
don't know if you've been following this
but i know
you're you're you're a bit philosophical
right yeah
so what what are you what's your
thoughts on what's been gone in this
past year and like
the grammys for instance i mean it used
to be like
you know 95 music and five percent you
know
let's take this opportunity to remember
that like killing
unarmed civilians uh you know
and calling them gamerword with your arm
with your boot on their neck in their
dying moments is not the way to uh
progress forward as a nation now it's
like a hundred and ten percent
statements and like one percent
music music and i you know people are
gonna say oh that's way more percentage
points
than logic permits so i'm gonna pass it
along to the
the smart looking guy here to explain
that i think accomplice is a legal term
for meaning that you're there for the
crime so i mean that's like a legal term
uh it's a weird word to use at the
grammys when you're talking about
street violence definitely yeah when
you're talking about people burning down
a wendy's that had nothing to do with
anything
but i guess they were mad the wendy's
employees called the police because
there was a drunk driver blocking their
driveway
and so they called so then decided to
burn the wendy's down
does that make sense no it doesn't make
sense but
like i think they're um they're they've
got premises
that most people unfortunately have so
like do you ever hear people saying like
um we gotta stop big tech you know we
gotta stop letting big tech treat us
this way so they're taking all these
separate companies grouping them
as though they're a monolith and wanting
to basically either punish them or
hamper them collectively
so why shouldn't uh all stores around
the neighborhood get punished
collectively
if people are upset at the police that's
this is not a stretch this is not a
reach i'm i think i'm
making a point you're not going to hear
anywhere but the tim cass podcast please
go to timcast.org
um there's a big difference between a
fast food restaurant that called the
cops
and big tech companies that actually
have meetings together and are proven to
actually collude with each other to
remove
political dissent so like there's not a
concerted effort among wendy's
mcdonald's and burger king
to to frame black individuals who fall
asleep in their driveways
it was just some employee who was like
yo there's some guy like sleeping in the
driveway can you help us
and then when he fought the cops he
ended up losing his life which is bad by
the way i mean cops should not
be judge jury executioner but this is a
guy who grabbed a taser and turned and
was trying to fire at the cop
you can argue if the cops should not
have used lethal force or whatever
that's that's something but
look you you know as well as i do people
talk about silicon valley as if it's a
monolith so yeah
maybe twitter facebook facebook twitter
and youtube may be met together but at
the same time there's like a trillion
other companies that are hoping to
someday be at that level
they're doing plenty of work and these
companies are also trying to compete
against one another
but they're they're lumped together
mentally as though they're a monolith
and i'm just i'm just pointing that out
that's all that's a good point
thank you we can move on corporate media
that gets thrown around i don't trust
the corporate media
tim cass doc tim cass is a corporation
it's a media corporation i trust it
i work for it but like yeah i i guess i
agree
you know we can absolutely do that i
think in terms of big tax silicon valley
there's kind of like a theme people tend
to be getting at they control technology
and infrastructure and then with like
wendy's getting burnt to the ground
i don't know would you support you know
google being brought to the ground
because
activists were mad at those hate speech
on it of course not i don't i don't
support even demonizing google or
or uh condemning these companies in the
vast majority of cases or in some cases
yeah criticize them harshly but uh
obviously i don't i don't allow any
level of violence by private citizens um
we we got a rule of law hmm rule of law
i mean and you see i know i hate to
bring this up five minutes into the show
but when you look at the capital
storming you're seeing a bunch of
reckless people treating
everyone in that building as though
they're part of this
uh concerted effort to uh deprive them
of their
of their rights or something like that i
mean we need to think critically we need
to be clear
so well so what are your thoughts on uh
just like i guess the wokification and
the activist
activistification of media and like you
know
the grammys awards shows commercials
commercial products
i'll i'll put it this way you know
you're talking
it sounds like you're in defense of
these these corporations to a certain
degree is that fair to say
depends what they're being accused of
sure sure
uh i'm i'm saying like you know i see
two big power monopolies government and
corporations
and i think left unchecked power tends
to corrupt absolutely
so i don't care if you're the government
i don't care if you're
big oil or big tech or big wendy's
you know or other grammy's pushing out a
political message i think it's a problem
when
too much power is concentrated in a
specific area
you don't think you're what someone
could call big youtuber
i'm big i'm a youtuber you're a big
youtuber
you have a lot more influence than a lot
of people so like
you could always look at somebody much
bigger and say oh they no one should
have that much power but we know it's
not
power power is force power is pointing a
gun at somebody okay now we're getting
demonetized
i meant meta well no actually i mean
that's fine yeah i mean i talked about
the killing of a dude by cops
i think we need to differentiate
economic power from political power and
the more we conflate the two
the more we conflate political and
economic power the more we're going to
see
economic power become the government
that is
corporations have friends in washington
and and we'll so we're going to see
political power basically politicians
taking over the economy taking over
industry so it's an ugly thing to
watch it but it's been happening over
100 years over
longer than 100 years so like keep in
mind a lot of the outrageousness we see
today
is like the culmination of decades and
decades and decades
of of these changes taking place so
there was always radicals
talking about killing cops for many
decades um we've had all types of
shenanigans people burning down the city
when they're
unsatisfied this goes back probably to
the days of like irish people in the
19th century or whatnot i don't mean to
insult any irish people i love gingers i
love everybody who
looks like that um i'm just saying
light was like the um what do you guys
know what that thing was in chicago
where the anarchists like there was an
explosion what was that what was that i
don't know that much about it i used to
know a lot more about this i forgot it's
been
it's been a minute but i think that's a
fair point uh to mention too is that
like
the extremism used to be substantially
worse i think in not just this country
but many other countries
where you actually had like you know the
weather underground was planting bombs
and actually detonating them
now we have widespread riding over the
past year which
arguably could be worse and that's
causing way more damage disrupting way
more people's lives
but i think you know you go back a
hundred years this is really bad
i mean you you've had treason you've had
sedition you've had
literal plots that involve high-powered
weapons and warships
and we're actually it's kind of like
fading a bit you know in the conflicts
we're getting into now
are mostly people protesting and pushing
each other and shoving
some people get arrested and they scream
police brutality and then they they do
burn down buildings and stuff so my fear
is whether or not this escalates
into more serious violence that's what i
don't want to happen
there's no question that crime has gone
down overall over the last few decades
i i don't think there's any question of
that so like overall we've gotten more
civilized but like what we've seen
not just this not just in 2020 but i
mean you know there's been
plenty of rioting and looting and all
types of outrageous stuff happening
you know for for some time but like 2020
was the year
of get no more f's to give right yeah
and um i don't feel like this country is
my home anymore
you know that's kind of the feeling i
got in the summer of 2020 that's how i
felt on january 6th
and i know someone's going to comment oh
that's 20 21.
how about i come over there and we
settle this get all of your little
uh dvd collecting proud boys and i'll
get all my blm
people and we'll settle this commenters
i'm
going to find every last one of you what
do you mean summer of 2020 you talking
about the the
yeah the the rioting the the elements
burning down wendy's and
private private businesses and um
uh police stations i mean it's out
absolutely uh disheartening to say the
least and um
and i was wondering is it gonna seep
into residential areas like what what it
does
okay but i mean is it gonna basically
just be home after home getting
broken into and that's it goodbye to any
semblance of civilization i just had a
horrific
uh portent about the chinese military
invading and
swiftly taking over the united states
like a blitzkrieg like if we were stupid
enough to
to let her go like they were running war
games and they're like no we can't stop
the chinese if they attacked us
no we talked uh about this with james
lindsay are you familiar with with james
maybe he he's he's like a very uh he's a
he's a the preeminent scholar on
critical race theory in in terms of
criticizing it and what's what it's
doing and this like wokeness and things
like that
and what he was mentioning when it comes
to china is that they're using political
warfare
so it seems more like they're
interfering in our culture they're
interfering in our advertisements our
our
you know cultural creations our tv shows
our radio programs our schools and
things like that
so you end up with ultra woke grammys
asking for people to basically commit
crimes
this is the thing this performance they
did and the reason i think it's
important to bring up is that
it's not that they're directly saying
hey go commit crimes they're showing
riots
viewing those riots as the good guys
like they're depicting that is they're
the good guys the cops the bad guys the
people burning down the buildings or the
black lives matter activists who are
fighting
the who are the good guys then they say
we need accomplices
they're advocating for tearing ourselves
apart
this is people in the united states
pointing the finger at the united states
and saying
burn it down burn it all down that's a
direct quote from a lot of these
activists they've judged up on cars and
they've yelled burn it all down
do you think people in china do that
they don't now first and foremost
they're not legally allowed to and
that's that's kind of scary
that you've got these two views in the
u.s you're allowed to so we actually
just fight ourselves and scream at each
other
and then in china they're forced to you
know this authoritarian system keeps
them in line
and they're growing rapidly they're
expanding
engaging in political warfare with us
and then we're on the verge of falling
apart
i mean that was a bold statement you
just made which statement you didn't
feel like this was your country i mean
it was a true statement it was an
emotional uh
tell i mean yeah like seeing uh you know
melrose avenue beverly hills
seeing you know seeing beautiful things
destroyed and
not only destroyed but being like
apologized for
that meaning like people downplaying the
severity of it and people
encouraging it um i just i don't feel
like la
is a city where i could meet somebody in
the street and and feel a bond with them
now obviously a lot of people were not
happy with what took place to put it
lightly but
but i mean the fact that culturally
people are comfortable
encouraging such behavior says that
morally you know in in the way people
think about ethics these
people have the people committing that
type of violence have the moral high
ground that's why they're comfortable
getting on the grammys and
and saying we need accomplices so i mean
the question to ask is not i think not
so much what's wrong with critical race
theory but what's the alternative what
are you offering
as an alternative classical liberalism
interesting
interesting uh statement yeah now what
does that mean to you
classical liberalism is typically about
protecting the rights of the individual
and i mean that's the strongest uh way
to put it
so i don't know is there any more
specific well i mean uh i think
versus like what we're saying with
critical race theory is race-based
collectivism
so we can get into yeah i mean i i i
like where you're going with this but is
there a period of time
in american history for instance you
would say that's like when the classical
liberals hung out
what do you mean like would you say the
founding fathers would you say
the 1940s like is there a period of time
no
uh there's some there's some elements of
classical liberal
liberalism that have existed in the
united states various at various periods
but it's never been like
has it ever been more than less is there
is there like i
i don't think the us has ever been
mostly
classically liberal or libertarian in
that regard interesting
if you go back to the founding fathers
for instance slavery like there's no
question
people were kept as property and more
importantly while the the ideas
of classical liberalism helped drive the
idea that
we no longer had to be under the knee of
some
you know divine prominence the king
declaring it we certainly didn't have
absolute freedoms there was cultural
uh enforcement of various ideas women
not be able to do certain things
certain things but we've progressed
greatly my issue now is that we got to
this period where it was like it was
almost going to get pretty good you know
in the 90s we saw censorship
but we had that air we had people like
george carlin and we had you know
he was he was willing to be offensive
and say things that really ruffled
feathers we do have people like that
today still
now we're starting to get hard pushback
for more moral authoritarians again
and so my my my thing is like we we
don't want critical race theory we want
race-based collectivism
that to me is nightmarish right there's
this guy who just went viral early today
because he he tweeted to bill burr
who's got a black wife that it may be a
sign of racism
and he referred to bill burr's wife and
he's claiming he didn't but he did
as a minority
adult use slave we'll put it that way
like sally hemmings
he he he literally claimed like bill
burr was keeping this woman around for
his pleasure as a slave and it was one
of the most shockingly disgusting things
i've heard from a critical race theorist
so i'm like hey let's respect the
individual let's live and let live let's
let's have some so we need some
regulation and some restriction but we
mostly want individual freedom
we there's there's an interesting debate
in the idea of collectivism in that
there does have to be
some not none but that we're going in
the wrong direction with it
does that answer your question am i did
i do a good job i mean you gave me your
point of view um i so i think the topic
of slavery and women's suffrage
complicates things in a way that's
difficult for me to make the point that
i'm trying to make but
obviously in most of history slavery and
ownership of women basically
uh pushing you know telling women what
to do has been the norm i think your
co-host looks like he still supports
those things
why are you wrecking on the end so much
man you got to have that guy
it's like a grounding rod yeah um ian's
the opposite of those things he's like
the leftiest guy on the show he's so
nice i can't understand much
[Laughter]
now but like in the so i think in their
time
uh the enlightenment thinkers you know
the age of reason as thomas paine i
think dubbed it uh people like benjamin
franklin thomas jefferson
george washington and you know people
joke people laugh at you now especially
people on the right they mock you for
saying this but
in their context in their time in
history even though slavery was a norm
even though women
were still largely seen as basically
trading cards
in their context they were taking a very
bold new step
yeah for man in drafting the declaration
of independence
saying life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness and they were going to have
property
did you know this they were going to
have property life liberty property and
the pursuit of happiness and i wish they
had
it in there in order to help us have a
lot more capitalism for a lot longer
possibly but you know why they didn't
have property in there
because they didn't they wanted to stick
it to the slave holders because they
knew they would use their
so-called property their slaves as an
extra vote or something like that
all right but so it when you look at
context when you see uh that when you
look at the history of philosophy and
all of the
uh great brave steps that it took to go
from
the um the just uh blurry and reckless
ancient and prehistoric even before that
prehistoric
times to get to a point where you have
intellectuals establishing a country
being willing to fight for it but then
once the war is won to sit and debate
painstakingly
and to um to look at ask what is human
nature what is the best
type of society for a human being to
live and to pursue life liberty
and his own happiness to get to that
point is a magnificent intellectual
achievement that we take for granted so
when i say classical liberal i'm talking
about those guys i'm talking about the
age of reason
and i'm not talking about what came
after them especially in america
like intellectuals that pragmatists
utilitarians
uh progressives obviously and of course
we get the post-moderns and we get the
uh you know the critical race theorists
which is probably
an offshoot of post-modern or something
i'm not i'm not an expert like your
previous guest
go i agree with you on the founding
fathers they it a lot of people don't
realize this but it wasn't just a
political revolution it was an
ideological revolution
a lot of people a lot of countries on
the world were under the crown or some
monarch
or some autocrat or some kind of system
where it was you know these kings would
say by divine providence
i am the king god wills it you know and
then they would just tell people do it
or else and they had people who are
loyal to that idea and to them
and then all of a sudden you get these
this this group of people in the in the
u.s
some of some of them i i've read a
little bit about this
the authority of the founding fathers
was questioned even by some like based
on how they were voted to represent the
colony they came from because it was
like
who saith this colony that you represent
them and want independence
but is there a lot of people who are
like yo we don't need a king
we can rule by the consent of the
government we can create something new
it's truly profound and there were a lot
of ideas but i think when you look back
at history
while i absolutely take the good from
the founding fathers
i've got the coin collection for thomas
jefferson i love it i think the dude was
a genius
i also think he was a product of his
times there's a lot of things back then
we criticize
the reason i don't highlight all of
those and emphasize them and condemn the
founding fathers over those things is
that we've changed
and we don't want to be like we hate
these people because they did bad things
and he was like
we want to say they did bad things but
here these really really good things
we're keeping now
but i don't think it's fair to point out
i mean they did a lot of bad things but
that we're not here to talk about them
as people we're talking about the ideas
that they promoted and the effect they
what made them stand out in history and
so while i agree with you
about the founding fathers for their
time was a radical bunch of classical
liberal types fighting for
the rights of the individual against
this king willing to literally fight and
die
and many of the signatories of the
declaration of independence had their
legacies their names and their lives
stripped away from them
it was that was a bold and amazing bunch
of people thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time